الدكتور تايسون بيل مدير
وحدة العناية المركزة الطبية في جامعة
فيرجينيا معنا الآن هو أيضًا
أستاذ مشارك في الأمراض
المعدية وطبيب طب
الرئة والعناية المركزة.  لقد انتهينا من ذلك
حول متغير mu ومدى
فعاليته وكيف
ترى توازن
العلاج وكل هذه المتغيرات
التي من المرجح أن تكون
على سطح السفينة وما بعده
جيدًا أولاً ، شكرًا لك على استضافتي
في العرض لمناقشة هذا  هذا
موضوع مهم للغاية لأنه كلما ظهر متغير جديد ،
يتعين علينا
الانتباه إليه ،
لذلك تم اكتشاف متغير mu لأول مرة
في كولومبيا يناير من هذا العام
وهو البديل الخامس المثير للقلق
الذي تم
تأكيده في 39  البلدان بما في ذلك هنا
في الولايات المتحدة
الآن لديها كوكبة من
الطفرات التي يمكن أن تشير إلى أنها
يمكن أن تكون مقاومة أو تتجنب
الاستجابات المناعية التي  إما بسبب
لقاح أو عن طريق عدوى طبيعية ، لكن من
المهم التأكيد على أن هذه
بيانات معملية ، من الصعب في الواقع
التنبؤ بكيفية تصرف المتغير
في المجتمع بناءً على طفرته ،
لذا يتعين علينا جمع المزيد من البيانات
السريرية ومراقبتها  لكن النقطة
الأهم هنا هي أن لدينا جزءًا كبيرًا من
سكان العالم الذين لا يزالون
غير محصنين ، وإذا لم نتحكم في
انتشار الفيروس ، فسنظل لدينا
متغيرات منبثقة وعلينا
الانتباه إلى ذلك
أعادنا إلى المربع الأول الآن في كولومبيا ،
كان معدل التطعيم لديهم
يزيد قليلاً عن ربع سكانهم بالكامل ،
لذا فهذه بيئات
نضجت فيها لمزيد من التباين ،
لذا يتعين علينا حقًا المضي قدمًا في
تطعيم العالم  حتى
نتمكن أخيرًا
من معرفة وضع التباين المستقبلي
الذي تعرفه يقلل من هذا الخطر الذي سيكون
لدينا المزيد